le premier site que j'ai eu à faire
c'était c'était tout autour de
l'érotisme et du porno en fait je
vendais du bois bandé
comme vous le savez désormais l'émission
s'organise autour d'un invité principal
ce soir Florence
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir Florence
très heureux de vous accueillir ce soir
parce que selon un sondage FHM TNS
Sofres vous êtes officiellement la
française préférée des Français
la big up en plan on se Foresti la
française
des Français
[Musique]
tu es énorme hein en fait c'est un
sondage qui avait été commandé par
Sarkozy et Cécilia était parti pour
savoir qui il allait épouser ces GLA lui
a présenté
j'ai rêvé que je sortais avec Sarkozy
cette nuit c'est très bizarre
parce que le lendemain quand on rêve de
quelqu'un c'est le lendemain on l'aime
pas et ben là je suis amoureuse de
Sarkozy demain plus aujourd'hui
c'est mon inconscient en tous les cas si
c'est galère lui avait pas présenté
Carla Boni
ça doit pas arrêter les Françaises
préférés des français en dehors de tout
aspect physique quand même
intéressant moi j'ai cru que
c'était donc j'ai dit c'est une blague
et j'ai appelé et en effet c'est tout
critères confondu sauf bien sûr parce
que quand on leur demande à ces hommes
avec iriez-vous dîner ou avec qui et
vous sur une île déserte c'est Clara
Morgane
alors derrière vous dans ce sondage Yann
Romanov Mimie Mathy bien sûr c'est en
dehors de tout aspect physique mais là
c'est
vous êtes ignoble alors votre chien
était élu chien préféré des Français ça
pourrait votre fille Tony a été élu bébé
préféré des Français c'est clair et net
elle vous en veux pas pour le prénom
attends ça va être la classe bon à part
que tous les commerçants la prennent
pour un garçon
comme sa mère
[Applaudissements]
pour le chien et pour Florence
[Musique]
voilà alors donc camper nous parlerons
de vous Florence de vos origines de
votre vie de votre succès de votre DVD
de l'abribus la comédie de Philippe elno
vous allez jouer l'année dernière à la
gaieté Montparnasse la pièce préférée
des Français
en P2 nous commanderons l'actualité de
la semaine en compagnie de Eric work
ministre du Budget et de serge Raffy
rédacteur en chef au Nouvel Observateur
voilà et en P3 nous recevrons Béatrice
Preciado qui publie testo junkie chez
Grassé alors c'est le journal de son
auto-intoxication la testostérone
celle-ci qui s'est mis les hormones
mâles si vous voulez pendant 236 jours
alors à la fin le gueuler quand le frigo
était vide elle se grattait les couilles
elle comprenait la règle d'or voilà
alors Florence Foresti il faut dire
qu'au départ c'était pas gagné vous êtes
né au mois de novembre déjà à Vénissieux
au minguette Père industriel mère dans
les ressources humaines sœur dans
l'hôtellerie voilà tout pour faire une
carrière tu vois et pourtant lisser vous
vous commencez à rêver au métier que
vous faites aujourd'hui et vous
découvrirez en demandant au mec de
sortir avec vous vous découvrez vous
êtes drôle enfin je découvre
on a tout comme un autre pour attirer
l'attention oui moi je développe plutôt
celui-là ouais ensuite le bac option
théâtre et école de cinéma vous voulez
faire chômeuse dans la vie non oui c'est
ça
bohème je voulais faire la vie de bohème
c'est pas faux vestiaire dans une boîte
c'est pas faux
s'il vous plaît c'était en franc tu
imagines et puis voilà tout ça avant de
devenir infographiste j'ai déjà lu
l'infographie c'était préféré des
Français
dans ma société sans doute
Internet et le premier site que j'ai eu
à faire c'était c'était tout autour de
l'érotisme et du porno en fait je
vendais du bois bandé
le graphiste au départ
j'ai une grande culture aussi
mais vous étiez déjà évidemment attiré
par les planches j'ai fait des cours de
théâtre classique
et tout très sérieuses les gens se
promenaient au sérieux c'était terrible
donc café théâtre amateur avec vos
premiers sketchs souvent des histoires
de célibataire on est bien placé pour
parler de ce qu'on connait non mais ceci
dit j'ai eu plein de mecs attendez
non mais je trouve toujours que le
célibat le célibat est beaucoup plus
drôle que la vie en couple enfin je veux
dire il y a plus de sujets dans les dans
les histoires de séduction de rupture de
râteau c'est toujours beaucoup plus gros
que quelqu'un qui réussit sa vie
affective comme vous êtes mis en ménage
vous avez pas eu peur de ménage j'adore
cette expression quand je me suis mise
en ménage Thierry
Ry
jamais
définitif déjà
alors en 1998 donc il y a 10 ans vous
faites les taupes modèle votre premier
succès très très bien marché star à Lyon
star à Lyon est dans la région PACA
ouvert et en 2001 vous lancez en solo là
évidemment c'est le début du succès vous
avez fait un stage à Thalassa ouais
c'est vrai que vous avez quitté quand
vous êtes aperçu que George perdue puis
c'est dans la mer
elle est con cette vanne elle est très
con c'est vraiment une vanne pourrie
mais j'avais vraiment envie de la peur
bon alors votre première télé c'est
Burger Quiz c'est canal
Chabat c'est dur non non mais oui mais
bon voilà personne ne me sort voir tu
veux que je te remonte des images de toi
et que ta coupe comme ça
t'énerve non à l'époque mais maintenant
on va refaire le burger de la mort alors
quel est votre âge à 12 ans près alors
quelle est la couleur de Casimir quel
est le métier principal de Victor Hugo
vous préférez les éléphants ou les
hippopotames quelle star vous attire
sexuellement que mettons dans un
magnétoscope comment appelle-t-on
l'hymne français est-ce que vous n'avez
pas marre de toutes ces conneries
combien font 25 x 5 et enfin quel est le
contraire de je n'ai pas pété alors
et voilà il fallait ressortir les 10
réponses alors 23 ans orange écrivain je
l'avais eu le petit burger de la mort
attention alors 23 ans orange écrivain
et alors après bah merde
hippopotame et qu'est-ce qu'on met dans
un magnétoscope
et après j'ai gagné là après je me suis
arrêté quel est le contraire de j'ai pas
pété
viens donc après c'est Berne 20h10
pétanque Ruquier le DVD Florence Foresti
et des sketchs la cigale 700
[Musique]
voilà jusqu'à la pause bébé alors là
vous en fait vous vouliez pas d'enfants
oui je savais pas bon j'avais et puis
m'arrêter de travailler c'était vraiment
très nouveau pour moi j'avais toujours
été sur les planches tout le temps tout
le temps depuis 10 ans non-stop donc
c'est plus ça qui m'a un peu déprimé le
fait de plus jouer ça m'a ce qui s'est
passé en fait c'est que le bébé était un
bébé surprise comme on dit quoi tout à
fait comment on fait les bébés surprises
maintenant il y a beaucoup de choses
pour pas faire de bébés surprise
mais non mais il y a des des oublis
inconscients qui sont
des actes
c'est la fête de la vie privée
[Applaudissements]
parce qu'on est extrêmement discret faut
dire que c'est le Julien préfère les
Français
et que c'est un mec qui était manager de
tourner donc les emmerdes il connaît
d'avance il est habitué
la française préférée des Français ça
doit lui [ __ ] la pression quand même
on s'en fout un peu complètement
l'île déserte
voilà donc après Tony après le bébé donc
vous remontez sur scène bah en janvier
2008 pour l'abribus de Philippe elno
alors Xavier plein de propositions au
théâtre mais en fait vous avez préféré
choisir la proposition d'un vieux pote
c'est assez sympa c'est vrai que j'aime
bien retravailler avec des gens que j'ai
connu à mes débuts et puis j'aime bien
quand les gens me connaissent d'avant je
sais pas pourquoi je me dis je leur fais
plus confiance je me dis qu'ils sont là
pour d'autres raisons et puis voilà je
suis moins méfiante je suis j'adore ça
et puis surtout il avait écrit une très
belle pièce l'abribus donc le pitch
c'est une star qui tombe en panne en
rase campagne sans portable et qui
rencontre l'apiculteur locale le
postulat de départ c'est le postulat de
toutes les comédies romantiques
qu'est-ce qu'on a à faire ensemble rien
mais finalement on va donc là dessus il
y a pas de grosse surprise en revanche
dans l'interprétation on s'est beaucoup
amusé
malheureusement c'est une pièce qu'on a
pas pu tourner en province parce que
j'avais un tournage après de film mais
c'est pour ça qu'on tenait la sortir en
DVD quoi pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de Inna larditude abonnez-vous et mettez
un pouce bleu